مرحبا انا سفيان ثابت لنتابع معا ابرز
اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز وضمن ابرز
الاحداث
احتجاجات في تل ابيب بسبب التغييرات
القضائيه الكويت تطبع مئه الف نسخه من
القران بالسويديه لقاء بين بوتين
وبريكوجين بعد التصعيد واخبار اخرى لنتابع
معا
[موسيقى]
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فشله في تحقيق هذه
الاهداف ويحاول الترويج كما يقول
الفلسطينيون لي خطه جديده هذه الخطه تستند
الى السلطه الفلسطينيه واجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه التي باتت وفق الروايه
الاسرائيليه عاجزه عن السيطره الامنيه على
مخيم جنين تحديدا وتاتي ايضا هذه الخطه
بعد ايام قليله من زياره غير مسبوقه
للرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس بعد اكثر من
11 عاما لم يزر في هاجمين بعد العمليه زار
الرئيس محمود عباس جليل وقال بالحرف انه
يتعامل مع الضفه الغربيه كلها على انها
دوله واحده وقانون واحد واجهزه امنيه
واجهزه امنيه واحده وبالتالي قد ترتبط
هاتان الروايتان ببعضهما روايه ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يريد الاستعانه
باجهزه امل السلطه الفلسطينيه
باب الامن بين قوسين في مخيم جنين الذي
باتا يؤرق الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويضربه في
العمق اكثر من مره صهيب العصر شكرا جزيلا
لك
الى تطورات وردود الفعل المتواصله على
حادثه حرق نسخه من المصحف الشريف في
السويد اذ اعتمد مجلس حقوق الانسان في
جنيف مشروع قرار تقدمت به باكستان نيابه
عن منظمه التعاون الاسلامي لادانه اعمال
الكرايا الدينيه مثل حرق نسخه من المصحف
المشروع صوتت لصالحه 28 دوله معظمها
اسلاميه في مقابل 12 دوله عارضته اغلبها
من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بالاضافه الى
بريطانيا والولايات المتحده في سياق متصل
مجلس الوزراء الكويتي يقرر طباعه مئه الف
نسخه من المصحف الشريف مترجمه للغه
السويديه لتوزيعها في السويد بهدف تاكيد
سماحه الدين الاسلامي ونشر القيم
الاسلاميه
الخطوه الكويتيه لقيت استحسانا وقبولا بين
رواد المنصات لنقرا بعض التعليقات صار بنت
محمد تقول الان الكويت تقوم بعمل كبير سوف
يساهم بتعريف شعب السويد بالاسلام من خلال
طباعه نسخ من القران باللغه السويديه
وتوزعها في السويده عمل رائع تشكر عليه
دوله الكويت نريد كل دوله عربيه اسلاميه
ان تعمل ما تقدر عليه وما تراه مناسبا لها
نصره لله تعالى تقول ساره اما يعقوب
الناصر فكتب ازاله الجهل بالعقل الى
العاصمه الليتوانيه فينيوس حيث اختتمت
اعمال قمه حلف شمال الاطلسي بتاكيد الحلف
على تقديم دعم قوي لاوكرانيا الحلفاء
اتفقوا على حزمه من ثلاثه اجزاء لتقريب
اوكرانيا من الحلفه بينما وقعت دول مجموعه
السبع الصناعيه اعلانا مشتركا بش ان
ضماناتنا امنيه لقياده كما افاد الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن بان قاده الحلف اتفقوا
على ان تكون اوكرانيا عضوا بعد الحرب
بدوره وصف زيليسكي نتائج قمه النيتو
بالجيده وقال انها ستصبح مثاليه اذا تلقت
بلاده دعوه للانضمام للحلفه يمكنكم متابعه
المزيد عن مجريات القمه في التقرير اسفل
التعليقات
من فينوس الى موسكو اذا اعلنا الكريم لاول
مره حدوث اجتماع بين بوتين وبريجوجن بعد
خمسه ايام من تصعيد مجموعه الاجتماع الذي
امتد له ثلاث ساعات تضمن عروضا لدمج
المجموعه في المجال العسكري ففي مقابله مع
صحيفه كوميرسانتاروسيه قال بوتين انه عرض
على مقاتل فاغنر فرصه لمواصله الخدمه داخل
الجيش الروسي النظامي كما ابلغهم بامكانيه
مواصلتهم القتال في اوكرانيا الامر الذي
رفضه ومقاتلوه واكد الرئيس الروسي ان
الامر متروك للبرلمان والحكومه لمناقشه
الاطار القانوني للمجموعات العسكريه
الخاصه ينضم الينا من موسكو الكاتب
والمحلل السياسيا
مرحبا
ثقته بالمجموعه مجموعه فاغن
لو لم تكن هناك ثقه المعينه والنسبيه على
الاقل بين الرئيس الروسي وفريج لما كان
هناك اللقاء بينهما ولكن قد شاهدنا هذه
المحادثات
وكذلك وضع امامنا ان توجد هناك تفاهمات او
مستقبل حول يعني او يوجد هناك حتى للاعلام
يبدو الاتفاق
وبعض البنود التي تحتاج لتنفيذها توجد
هناك تفاهمات حول انتقاله الى بيروسيا
فطبعا هذا يشير الى ان تنسيق لا يزال
موجود بين بوتين وايضا الرئيس الروسي قادر
بدور مقاتلي ذلك الشخصي توجد هناك رغبه
لدى سقوطات الروسيه لكي يستمروا في مشاركه
في العمليه القتاليه
شكرا سيد اندريه الى اخر اخبارنا هذا
الاسبوع فقد اعلن الملياردير الامريكي
ايلون ماسك عن اطلاق شركه جديده متخصصه في
الذكاء الاصطناعي تحت اسم اكس اي اي تشير
الشركه الناشئه عبر موقعها الالكتروني الا
انها تهدف الى فهم الطبيعه الفعليه للكون
وفي خبر اخر مرتبط بالذكاء الاصطناعي
دائما فقد صوت قاده اتحاد الممثلين في
هوليود للانضمام الى كتاب السيناريو في
اول اضراب مشترك منذ اكثر من سته عقود ما
ادح الى اغلاق استوديوهات الانتاج في لوس
انجلوس بكاليفورنيا ليدخل قطاع انتاج
المسلسلات والافلام في هوليود مرحله جنود
كلي من شانه ان يؤدي الى اسوا شلل في
القطاع كتاب السيناريو والممثلون رفعوا
عددا من المطالب من ابرزها توفير ضمانات
في حال تضرر عملهم نتيجه برامج الذكاء
الاصطناعي ورفع الاجور شاركونا ارائكم في
التعليقات هل الذكاء الاصطناعي يشكل لك
تخوفا من فقدان وظيفتك
بهذا نصل الى نهايه ايجاز الاسبوع نلتقي
بكم في ايجاز اخر الاسبوع القادم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]